la situation des droits humains et des
libertés en tunisie est meilleur que
sous le régime de ben et magne
même si nous avons
gagner sur ce plan puisque aujourd'hui
nous avons le droit de constituer des
organisations de défense des droits
humains des organisations de tous genres
nous avons le droit de constituer des
partis nous avons le droit de manifester
le droit de nous réunir le droit
d'organiser des sit in et le droit de
nous présenter aux élections
présidentielles et aux élections
législatives
seulement je toujours dit qu'il faut
rester vigilant et continuer de défendre
ses droits et ses libertés parce que il
ya des tentatives de vous les arracher
de nouveau par exemple le droit de
manifester
je crois que ce droit est menacé puisque
les gens qui manifestent dès fois se
retrouvent dans des postes de police ils
sont sauvagement agressés ils peuvent
même être torturés
donc je crois que l'objectif c'est de
terroriser de nouveau les tunisiens pour
qu'ils arrêtent de 2,2
comment dire d'entraidé revendiquer leur
droit de kiel qu'ils arrêtent de
manifester qu'ils arrêtent de de
s'exprimer librement